IT'S TIME TO PLAY OUR NEXT GAME
"SWEET EMOJI."
(LAUGHTER)
EMOJI IS SOMETHING PEOPLE USE TO
LET OTHER PEOPLE KNOW JUST HOW
THE THING THEY TYPED MAKES THEM
FEEL.
IT'S WAY EASIER THAN USING WORDS
AND MUCH MORE EFFICIENT THAN
ACTUAL HUMAN INTERACTION SO I'M
GOING TO SHOW YOU A SERIES OF
EMOJI AND FOR 250 POINTS I WANT
YOU TO TRANSLATE THE SENTENCE.
ALL RIGHT?
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
HOWARD KREMER?
>> "I WALKED DOWN TO GOLD'S GYM
FOR ALL THE (BLEEP)"
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: POINTS!
(LAUGHTER)
WHICH GOLD'S JIM ARE YOU GOING
TO?
(LAUGHTER)
I DON'T THINK I'M GOING TO THAT
ONE.
NEXT ONE.
JONAH?
>> IT'S -- OH!
WHAT'S THAT POODLE?
YOU KNOW WHERE I CAN SCORE SOME
SWEET "H"?
(LAUGHTER).
>> Chris: POINTS!
POINTS!
OH, WAIT, DID YOU HAVE ONE,
HOWARD?
>> IT WAS RELAX AGO BIT BEFORE I
PUT THE DOG DOWN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
POINTS!
WHAT IS THAT?
YES, JONAH RAY?
>> IN THE (BLEEP) IN THE (BLEEP)
IT'S ALL OKAY FOR ME!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OKAY, I'LL GIVE YOU
POINTS.
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS.
YES?
>> MY CAT LOVES CHOCOLATE AND
THE FAWNS.
>> Chris: POINTS!
YES, SURE, HOWARD.
>> CAT (BLEEP) RULES!
>> Chris: IT DOES!
(APPLAUSE)